last Thursday when we were still in Los
Angeles I announced that our staff the
entire staff was gonna be hopping on a
plane and flying out here for our week
so in New York I shouldn't say the
entire staff it was all of us except for
my pal Andy Richter right
you see I told Andy and I got to talk
about you as if you weren't here that's
okay but I told Andy he was going to be
going to have to get to New York
by taking a road trip that's right I
surprised Andy by giving him a new chevy
sonic to make the trip he left directly
from our studio and it was very dramatic
you didn't seem prepared well I wasn't
prepared yeah you know but how was the
how was the trip
it was good I mean we made good time we
got here in about three days
I guess across country yeah yeah yeah
well you know you didn't give me a lot
of choice yeah I did hear too many to
make the show I think you I'm acting
surprised yeah yeah yeah it was it was
it was fun but it was it was exhausting
my you know I'd there were some people
with me we recorded the whole thing and
you can look at it now if you'd like
[Applause]
[Music]
we're here in Barstow California which
is beginning of Route 40 u.s. 40 which
is going to be our main road East and
I've decided that at every stop I'm
going to buy little something for the
car and I decided to start with a
classic baby don't worry you're gonna be
smelling nice now
[Music]
during the galaxy diner flag set they
have lots of old Hollywood pictures but
they do have some current ones because I
found one of Conan you and Jack Lemmon
with Jack
[Music]
okay calling I'm calling Conan on his
cellphone he's in New York
I've been forwarded to an automatic
voice-message Conan it's Andy calling
you from the road
it's great how is your flight
the kind of snacks that they have does
the smell of I think with your message
press one so it can be a message press
two I'm not satisfied
there's the wigwam motel but have you
slept in a wigwam plate
check out meteor crater which apparently
is a crater that was made by a meteor
well there it is
[Applause]
Hey darn it sandy again I've got cut off
yeah I just wondering how your trip was
if you rested if the smell of your own
body isn't making you sick
like it is mine I have to get off the
road and I have to shower or something
because I stink I stink bad I smell like
like somebody crapped yogurt
[Music]
I'm already redial
Coenen hi it's Andy hey how are you man
I'm the road yeah yeah listen I just
left your voicemail maybe I got a little
tired so maybe I got a little snappish
on the voicemail please hey Andy it's
the best time for me to talk to having a
bubble bath right now
[Music]
midnight Amarillo Texas the Big Texan
steak house
they say free 72-ounce steak free if you
can eat it all in an hour can I eat it
all in an hour I do it shouldn't but I'm
gonna try 72 ounces of steak baked
potato salad roll on three fried shrimp
if you get all in under an hour
that's that Oh shrimp
Friday we're in Little Rock have to do
one thing and if it's Friday that means
it's my birthday I'm 45 years old my dad
never done before I'm gonna take a
shower and a truck stop
my ass
[Music]
we're somewhere in Maryland I'm gonna be
coming up on some urban areas and I'd
like to take advantage of the carpool
lanes so I decided to take on a
passenger thanks to the Christmas gift
section at the Travel Center here ready
to go darling
all right
what oh I'm sorry I thought you said
something
[Music]
[Applause]
to the other side of the tunnel we would
be
and the short drive up town to the
Beacon Theater and we will be finished
here we are
[Music]
[Applause]
I made it somebody parked the car
but snowstorm fridge thematic at the end
yeah why it was quite a surprise
you